il faut effectivement salué l'effort des
travailleurs des ouvriers des
techniciens des ingénieurs du cnes qui
ont réussi cette performance
ariane est désormais qualifié et nous
allons pouvoir entrer dans l'ère des
tirs commerciaux à partir de 1982 je
crois que la france et l'europe pour
montrer que elle était capable d'exister
de manière indépendante en matière
spatiale indépendamment donc de l'urss
et des états unis
vous comptez ils ont tellement augmenté
le budget spatial européen
enfin pour ce qui concerne la france
bien sûr le budget français pour
commencer
disons que il est sur orbite on va
continuer l'effort pour développer la
famille ariane pour construire la fusée
ariane 4 français une décision qui va
être prise dans les prochaines semaines
cette fusée permettra de satelliser des
charges plus lourdes
environ une tonne et demie de fait sont
envoyés dans l'espace et cette élite de
télécommunications de télévision directe
ou d'observations météorologiques par
exemple